there's quite a lot of difference but
also a lot of similarities between an
architect and an interior designer and
today i want to talk about how each
profession develops the concept and i
wanted to talk about the concept because
it's really the foundation of every
design project and it's something that
informs every aspect of the design and
fundamentally it's how we approach
problems and come up with solutions i'll
be talking about the difference in how
we approach problems i'll also be
talking about the hierarchy of
importance for each profession and how
this can lead to three different results
a portion of this video is sponsored by
soundcore more on them later in this
video of course this is based on my
personal observations i am an architect
trained as an architect and i went
through the traditional process of
becoming an architect but i did work at
an interior design slash architecture
firm where i was the only architect
working alongside other interior
designers and this process
was so interesting to me and so eye
opening and i actually saw a lot of
flaws in my own training and how i
approach design so if you're an interior
designer watching this please feel free
to share your thoughts and experiences
so that this comments section can become
a source of information for young people
who are trying to decide which
profession to go into i also have a
discord server where you can ask
questions and we have a pretty big
variety of people from different
professions and backgrounds and
experiences and skills so yeah if you
have any questions feel free to drop it
in there as well
so high level architects design the
building and interior designers design
within that shell but there's also a lot
of in-betweens and a lot of architects
do interior renovations and personally
i've worked on a lot of interior
renovations in my career and really
every project is unique based on the
client and the project type so keep that
in mind as you're watching this and if
you want a full breakdown of the
differences like of the project types
and the design process and the education
as well as the skills and personality
that's required to thrive in each career
check out the video right here i think
there's a lot of nuances to the way we
approach problems that's quite different
when it came to developing the concept
and i really try to distill it down to
the essence i think the biggest
difference is that architects derive
their concepts from external sources
and interior designers derive their
sources from internal sources let me
explain a concept is an idea that
becomes a foundation and identity of
every design project and it drives it
forward it's the idea that informs the
different aspects of your building in
every step of the design process and
whenever you're stuck you can refer back
to the concept to get some clarity in
your direction it's also a really good
way of embedding meaning into the
project that's beyond just the building
or the space itself but most importantly
it's a tool to get buy-in from clients
and your team and get everyone aligned
on the same page each office and each
designer is unique in their way of
developing a concept so try to learn
from others and as you work in different
offices try to also develop your own
methods
architects tend to derive their concepts
from external sources when you see an
architect presenting their work we
typically start off by describing the
context or the problems or opportunities
they see on the site or the program and
this is all of your physical or social
constraints of your project and when you
actually look at the most convincing
presenters like bjr gangels they distill
the problem into a really clear series
of diagrams or images and they use this
to develop their functional or formal or
material strategy which forms the basis
for their concept but this isn't the
case with just large buildings even when
architects are operating at a much
smaller scale like interior renovations
the way we present concepts is almost
always dependent on an external or
site-specific or program-specific source
let me just pause for a quick moment for
a message from our sponsor soundcore i
don't know about you guys but i feel
like i'm constantly surrounded by noise
and distractions and for me having a
device that can help me stay focused
really makes a difference soundcore
space a40 offers the perfect balance
between noise cancelling performance
sound quality and battery life as a
creator
i always try to absorb content as much
as possible so listening to audiobooks
whenever i can now is kind of a part of
my daily routine
the space a40 adaptive noise cancelling
feature automatically detects different
types of background noise and improves
word comprehension even at really high
reading speeds the dedicated soundcore
app lets you customize the noise
canceling parameters and and you can
even create a tailored sound experience
via sound id
which is a feature that generates an eq
profile based on your personal hearing
biometrics it creates a really rich and
vibrant sound experience that really
makes me wanna listen to music even more
plus these earbuds are really
lightweight and comfy to wear and they
also have really useful magnets that can
keep them together inside or even
outside of their charging box and with
one single charge you can get up to 10
hours of playing time check the link in
the description if you want to know more
i'll give you an example with the
project that i'm working on right now
which is the library renovation where
the driving concept is this idea of the
urban courtyard this was from a series
of contextual factors the library has
this really beautiful
garden that already kind of functions as
a central green space in this very dense
neighborhood and you can see this solid
void relationship within that building
as well when you enter the building
you've got this big three-story atrium
and the library is also in a really
diverse neighborhood it's got a really
high percentage of immigrants and people
whose first language is not english the
functional program of the library is
also pretty diverse we're putting in a
digital media lab a lounge a recording
studio a grab-and-go section so we
developed this idea of the urban
courtyard
[Music]
and courtyards have been pretty
universal across different cultures
throughout history and although it first
came to place to control the
microclimatic conditions within
buildings over time it evolved to become
a social gathering place and so this
shared architectural language of the
courtyard brings these diverse cultures
and programs together while also
bringing in an element of nature you can
see how we developed the concept by
tying it to some of these external
conditions the broader and more flexible
your concept is the better because you
can tie it to a lot of different aspects
of the design for example the courtyard
this can be functional or formal or
social or organizational and it has a
lot of visual associations so it can be
also used to develop your material
strategy but a concept like let's say
a digital hub which is an idea that
we've been talking a lot about it
doesn't have a lot of historical or
architectural or visual associations so
it's a little bit harder to use it as a
concept even the most form-driven
architecture like frank gehry's work is
in some way relating to its context now
architects will take this and some
architects will create a mood board
which i'll go into in a little bit but
when it comes to the hierarchy of
importance for architects like based on
our training and our design philosophy
it's function
organization order
and then we have mood
for interior designers they don't really
have these complex site conditions to
work with right so they derive a lot of
their concept ideas from internal
sources and what i found is that the
concept development process in interior
design
is a lot more intimately connected to
the client
and their visions for the project and so
during this phase we just sit with the
client and we just talk about their
vision for the space not just
programmatically or functionally but how
they want the space to feel
and what's the image they want to
project and the client they can bring
their own inspiration images
and if it's like a commercial client
they can bring their own branding
guidelines and we basically work with
the client to put together visual
representation of this feeling which is
called a mood board but before doing
this we would
write a very small paragraph
or like a list of words
or a poem that kind of captures the mood
or the direction that we got from the
client and i found this process super
interesting for me language is not
really my strong suit so this was
definitely kind of hard for me but
first of all like it's a really really
great way to consolidate all the
information that you got from the client
but you're not just reciting what the
client is saying you're adding and
you're elevating all the things that
they said
into a language that have a visual
connection so for example we were
designing an office for a construction
company and some of the words that they
used was things like trustworthy
kind family business and so you could
use that to say something like grounded
and family roots and this kind of
descriptive writing it works hand in
hand with the mood board which is
basically a collection of images that
represent the mood or the feeling that
you're trying to create these images
aren't necessarily precedent images
they're literally like images that
combine together to create a mood
everyone probably has a slightly
different way of doing it but the way
that i was taught you shouldn't actually
include images of actual building
elements that actually comes in a little
bit later in the design process i've
seen a lot of different reactions to
this concept development process some
clients are a little bit more literal
and more pragmatic and they just want to
quickly move on to the actual design
but for a lot of clients they get really
involved and
they want to bring their own images and
because interior design is so much more
based on more elusive things compared to
architecture
like they're more focused on the mood of
the space
i think there's a much higher chance of
misalignment and so i think this step is
a really really good check-in point and
i think it's really essential for
everyone just to make sure that we're
all on the same page once you have the
mood board you pull together the colors
which become the basis for your material
board each profession is really unique
and each designer and each office is
really distinct in how they operate as
an architect i learned so much from that
time when i was working with interior
designers and i think one of the most
eye-opening things was the relationships
that they were building with the clients
and
maybe it's a result of this more
intimate process where you talk for
prolonged periods of time about the
client's desires but i found that
interior designers
in most cases had a much more
personal relationship with their clients
and i just thought it was a really
important element that i could take into
my work as an architect i hope this
video gave you a little bit of insight
into the differences and the nuances of
each profession if you have any
questions or thoughts on the topic
please let me know in the comments and
if you guys found this video helpful
make sure to give me a thumbs up
and i will see you guys in the next
video
[Music]
you